hasta el altar en bicicleta pero no
suenan campanas de boda sino de protesta
decenas de ciclistas acuden a la cita
anual de bendición de las bicicletas en
la catedral de San Juan el divino en
Nueva York creo que es una verdadera
parodia que sea tan peligroso ser
ciclista en la ciudad de Nueva York
especialmente desde la pandemia Parece
que la gente conduce de forma más
agresiva más rápido distraídos y todo
eso pone en riesgo la vida de los
ciclistas lo que nos mantendrá a salvo
son las infraestructuras como el carril
bici un decano de la Catedral
oficialista esta singular ceremonia que
cumple 25 años en honor a los ciclistas
que perdieron la vida en accidentes de
tránsito al menos 10 en lo que va de año
en pie y con las bicis estacionadas el
párroco rocía agua bendita sobre las
ruedas de los caballitos de acero para
proteger a sus dueños
tal vez no me siento más protegida pero
cuidada y es bueno saber que hay un
montón de gente por ahí en bicicleta que
quiere ir seguro y se preocupan por cómo
se Ejecutan las calles según estudios un
ciclista de Nueva York tiene 25 veces
más probabilidades de morir que un
ciclista de Vancouver o las mismas que
un ciclista en Argentina estas
bendiciones simbólicas no buscan salvar
vidas pero sí visibilizar esta
problemática